et je vais passer la parole à Dominique
Verrien rapporteur de la commission des
lois
mes chers collègues nous voici donc
réunis pour examiner deux textes portant
réforme de notre justice ces textes
suivent les états généraux de la justice
mais Agnès en a parlé je ne vais pas en
rajouter je vais plutôt me concentrer
sur les articles sur lesquels j'aurai à
vous répondre au nom de la commission
sur le projet de loi organique tout
d'abord s'il est utile d'ouvrir la
magistrature et d'augmenter le nombre de
magistrats nous devons aussi entendre la
défiance régulièrement exprimée à
l'égard de la justice certains pensant
les juges intouchables et il est vrai
qu'au vu du résultat des saisines du
Conseil supérieur de la magistrature
3224 au cours des 10 dernières années 88
jugés recevable cette plaintes renvoyées
0 sanctions on pourrait le croire or
l'indépendance de nos magistrats ne doit
pas se confondre avec l'irresponsabilité
c'est pourquoi l'article 8 élargit les
conditions de recevabilité des plaintes
des justiciables en retirant la
nécessité d'articuler des griefs
articuler les griefs un juriste est-ce
que c'est pas un justiciable lambda et
sous le prétexte que l'on ne savait pas
dire endroit qu'elle faute le juge avait
fait la demande était rejetée notre
Commission a également fait un choix de
compromis en supprimant l'obligation
d'audition systématique du magistrat
mais en clarifiant la définition de la
faute disciplinaire et en renforçant
l'échelle des sanctions maintenant un
sujet qui pourrait paraître anecdotique
mais ne l'est pas le niveau de diplôme
pour exercer la profession d'avocat
devient le Master 2 soit mais le décret
actuel qui définit les niveaux d'études
requis ne distingue pas le niveau pour
exercer le métier du niveau pour
intégrer le centre de formation or 8%
des élèves avocats n'ont qu'un M1 et
passe leur m2 en cours de formation
pourquoi se priver de ces élèves il n'y
a aucun il n'y a qu'un décret à changer
pour distinguer les deux niveaux
monsieur le ministre
sur le projet de loi maintenant je tiens
à saluer personnellement l'inscription
des pôles violences intrafamiliale dans
le rapport annexé un premier pas vers
une réponse globale suggéré par le plan
rouge vif qui est midi Chandler et
moi-même vous avez remis le 22 mai
dernier sur ce sujet nous avons fait le
choix avec ma collègue Cora porteur de
ne pas déposer d'autres amendements en
particulier par le biais du rapport
annexé après tout nous aurions pu faire
de ce rapport un inventaire à la Prévert
intégrant le rapport au rapport mais
nous souhaitions conserver à votre
rapport son statut d'orientation
monsieur le ministre c'est pour quoi
contre toute attente mes chers collègues
vous me verrez repousser certains
amendements pourtant issus du plan rouge
vif soit parce qu'il s'agit d'éléments
réglementaires dont le ministère est en
train de rédiger les décrets comme vous
l'avez annoncé soit parce que c'est du
financier et que cela doit être débattu
un projet de loi de finance soit bien
sûr sur le reste du texte à cause de
indique le 45 pour le reste ce texte
porte une réforme de notre justice
commerciale largement inspirée de
l'excellent travail de nos collègues
François bonhomme est à Nîmes Mohamed
souadi nous expérimenterons donc des
tribunaux des affaires économiques nous
avons souhaité rendre cette réforme plus
ambitieuse en les tendant à tous les
corps de métiers et en permettant à
l'expérimentation d'être dans des
conditions réelles à savoir avec des
juges consulaires issus des différentes
professions ajoutées autre point notable
l'instauration d'une contribution pour
la justice économique le Sénat est
favorable de longue date puisque c'était
proposé dans le rapport du questeur bas
de 2017 qui instaurait un droit de
timbre pour responsabilité
responsabiliser les justiciables tout en
finançant mieux la justice en général
attention toutefois monsieur le ministre
au montant de cette contribution en
particulier pour les acteurs économiques
en difficulté si celle-ci est pertinente
elle ne doit pas devenir un frein dans
l'accès à notre justice de plus outre un
barème affiné qui traduira votre
engagement de ne pas toucher
les petites entreprises il apparaît
particulièrement nécessaire d'engager
une réforme de l'accès à l'aide
Juridictionnaire pour en étant le
bénéfice aux personnes morales une telle
réforme que nous n'avons pu prendre pour
cause d'articles 40 pourraient être
compensés par cette nouvelle
contribution pour la justice économique
certains ont d'ailleurs demandé que
cette contribution soit fléchée vers les
tribunaux des affaires économiques cela
n'est pas cela n'est possible qu'un
projet de loi de finances mais il est
certain que cela devrait servir à la
justice et particulièrement à la justice
économique dont les juges consulaires
sont au-delà du bénévolat s'apparentant
souvent à des mécènes de voir payer pour
travailler voici un concept qui n'est
pas très juste pour perdurer dans un
tribunal en conclusion il vous reste
encore du travail monsieur le ministre
merci merci donc à mesdames les
rapporteurs et dans la suite de la
discussion